[Music]
hello friends this is Doug Batchelor how
about an amazing fact the world record
for the fastest that a human being has
ever run is held by a sane bolt who was
clocked at nearly 28 miles an hour in
the 100-meter sprint the current land
speed record stands at 763 miles an hour
set in October 1997 by British Royal Air
Force pilot Andy green driving the
jet-powered thrust SSC that stands for
supersonic car in Nevada's Black Rock
Desert the fastest that humans have ever
flown was achieved by the crew of NASA's
Apollo 10 moon mission Thomas Stafford
John W Young and Eugene Cernan as they
rocketed back to our planet from the
moon on may 26 1969 they reached a top
speed of 24,000 791 miles an hour that's
approximately 32 times the speed of
sound that 46 year old record still
remains today as the quickest that any
human beings have ever traveled but did
you know the Bible speaks of one
individual that apparently traveled even
faster stay with his friends were gonna
learn more as amazing facts brings you
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live with
author and evangelist pastor Doug
Batchelor is understanding God's Word a
challenge are they passages of scripture
that are a mystery to you maybe it's
difficult to reconcile what you've read
in the Bible to what you've always
believed if you have Bible related
questions stay tuned to get honest
practical answers straight from the Word
of God on Bible answers live Bible
answers live is a production of amazing
facts ministries dedicated to spreading
the gospel of jesus christ to the entire
world our lines are open
so call us now at 806-853-9949 7 and as
I mentioned you call now good chance
that you'll get your call on tonight's
broadcast 800 4 6 3 7 2 9 7 purpose of
the program is not to talk about romance
or finance but the Word of God so just
give us a call with your Bible questions
my name is Doug Batchelor
and pastor john ross is traveling back
from the east coast tonight and will be
with us next week but we're gonna go to
the phones after we have a word of
Prayer father in heaven thank you again
for this privilege of being able to
communicate with such a large family
through this miraculous medium of radio
and we just pray Lord you'll take charge
of every aspect of the program and that
we will hear truth and the power of the
truth will liberate we thank you pray
all this in Jesus name Amen well friends
I was teasing a little bit with a
question at the beginning talking about
who is the fastest person in the world
and we talked about the fastest runner
Usain Bolt and then you've got the
person who's driven the fastest Andy
green and then the crew of Apollo 10
that went through space at 24,000 miles
an hour actually twenty four thousand
seven
91 miles an hour but in the Bible it
talks about someone that may have even
broken the speed of light not just the
speed of sound couple of them you might
think about the Apostle Paul he says in
2nd Corinthians 12 verse 2 and 3 I know
a man in Christ who 14 years ago was
caught up to the third heaven and Paul
is probably speaking of himself being
caught up to the dwelling place of God
the Hebrews thought of three heavens
they had the atmosphere around the earth
was the first heaven the place in space
where the Sun Moon and stars hang is the
second heaven the third heaven was the
dwelling place of God which is obviously
a long way from Earth but he was caught
up there he can also read in the book of
Revelation how it talks about the
Apostle John you can read in Revelation
chapter 4 he says in Noah verse 4 verse
1 I looked and behold a door standing
open in heaven and he hears a voice that
says come up here and I will show you
what mice must take place after this and
at once instantly I was in the spirit
behold a throne stood in him and John
was raptured you might say up to heaven
and shown the vision of Revelation
that's pretty quick travel I even read
in the Book of Daniel how a God sent an
angel Gabriel when Daniel was praying
the angel says at the beginning of your
prayer I was sent and before he finishes
his prayer the angel gets from heaven
all the way to earth that's got to be
faster than the speed of light light
goes 186,000 miles per second God must
have something out there called the
speed of thought but whatever it is it's
a lot faster than anything we can
comprehend and there is a real place
called heaven
that's our free offer for tonight
friends and if you would like that book
heaven is it real heaven isn't real
talks about John being there Gabriel
being there paul was caught up to heaven
God has made it possible for you to be
there and maybe if you knew how real it
really was that would inspire you if
you'd like a free copy of this book all
you have to do is call it's free
nobody's gonna hassle you or bother you
just call asked for the book will
send it to you no strings attached
heaven is a true real call the phone
number 808 three five six seven four
seven for the free offer 808 three five
six seven four seven your Bible
questions call 800 four six three seven
two nine seven one more time Bible
questions 800 God says alright with that
we're gonna go to our phones and the
first call is from Lauren who's calling
from Charlotte North Carolina and North
Carolina welcome Lauren you're on the
air hi hi how are you doing I'm good you
alright what's your question tonight
alright my question is in Exodus 17
chapter 17 verse 16 and it says for he
said because the Lord has sworn the Lord
will have war with emilich from
generation to generation and my question
is who are the Amalekites now well the
Amalekites were pretty well wiped out by
the time of Esther
King Saul was told by civil first of all
you just gotta I know it's it really
troubles people when they hear that God
told one nation to basically uh Nile
eight another Latian a nation but the
Amalekites were the people that were
constantly attacking Israel as soon as
they came out of Egypt the first people
to attack the Israelites in the
wilderness and they attacked the old and
the weak that were straggling were the
Amalekites there were very cruel warlike
desert people they would live in the
deserts and they'd come raid Israel then
it charged back out into the desert
finally God told King Saul through
Samuel the Prophet go and wipe out
animal the Amalekites and he didn't wipe
them all out he left the King Agag and
evidently his family alive but they were
pretty well wiped out then you read in
the book of Esther Haman wanted to
annihilate all the Jews in the book of
Esther it says Haman was an egg a gate
he was a descendant of a gag or the
Amalekites and interestingly Mordecai
was a descendant of Benjamin are related
to King Saul so it's like that old
battle was continuing to wait there are
probably no Amalekite people per se
today they were pretty much exterminated
in the Old Testament times before Jesus
oh so yeah it's it's not like the
Ishmaelites you know the Ishmaelites are
largely the Arabs today or some of the
other descendents of Abraham from his
wife cateura
but the Amalekites pretty much we're
extinct you might say okay but good
question I know it sounds strange that
God would say I want you to have war on
Amalek from generation to generation and
they did until they were exterminated
thank you all right good question
appreciate that thank you Lauren and
we're gonna go then and talk to DOM
who's calling it from Vinland New Jersey
did I say that right Dom violin Vineland
okay and you're calling on listening on
WN CA welcome you're on Bible answers
live thank you your question how do we
overcome doubt and how do we increase
our faith in God's Word and there are
any stories and about anybody having
doubt and overcoming back oh well yeah
you've got you know thomas is referred
to as a doubter he said i'm not gonna
believe that Jesus rose from the dead
unless I can put my hand in the print of
the nails and thrust my hand in his side
he wanted to wanted evidence and then
when Jesus appeared to Thomas he said
don't be unbelieving but have faith and
he's often referred to as doubting
Thomas it's become sort of a nickname
for people but in the Bible you can read
and I believe it's Romans chapter 10 and
I think it's verse 17 it says faith
comes by hearing and hearing by the Word
of God the more that we read his word it
increases our faith and quite frankly
faith comes from evidence so when you
pray for big things and you get an
answer your faith gets bigger whenever
you have some you know remarkable answer
to prayer or when you you know ask for
God's guidance and he gives it to you it
increases your faith so faith is like a
muscle the more you use it the more it
will grow if it's neglected it will
atrophy
that makes very much sense yeah so you
know we have some lessons and studies
that talk about faith if you'd like
we'll send you a free copy of our study
guide called is there anything left I
can trust it's a good study guide to
talk about faith in the Bible and we'll
send that to you for free is there
anything left I can trust if you call
that resource number dumb and that's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven we'll send that out here and
the price is right it's a fifty percent
off free which makes it still free and
now we're gonna talk with Francesca
who's calling from New Jersey as well
listening on the Internet Francesca
you're on the air with Bible answers
live hi I just want to say you're
awesome and yes that was my husband that
just called you okay my question is what
advice you have for females in this
generation and have low self-esteem and
just how exactly are we supposed to cope
with that well when you say low
self-esteem what do you mean well I mean
like for example but some of the girls
out with we were like make up and I was
loved it I sold it of course but just
having to you know really look at
yourself in the mirror and saying I'm
okay with who I am and how I look and I
know that you guys had something online
saying how come bad god doesn't like
that but I'm just saying like in general
like you know so you could be more
confident about your appearance and and
well and you know we do have a couple of
books and you're right we've got a book
that it was written by Joe Cruz called
colorful cosmetics and jewelry and then
I wrote a book called jewelry how much
is too much and you know it's it's true
that sometimes people
be try to compensate they don't feel
like they're worth enough and they they
might compensate by buying expensive
things and wearing expensive clothing or
jewelry thinking that they're somehow
creasing their value but you're value
with God is not measured by what you see
in the mirror it's not measured by you
know outward ornaments Peter says in 2nd
Peter chapter 3 whose adorning do not
let it be the outward adorning the
plating of the hair and wearing of
apparel or putting out of gold but let
it be the hidden man of the heart which
in the sight of God is of great price or
great value and so God looks for the
inner ornamentation the inner adorning
where he says it's the ornament of a
meek and quiet spirit when we have the
holy spirit that's something on the
inside
you can't sell that to people by
knocking on the door I and when you
realize what you're worth you know how
you measure what something's worth
Francesca
mm-hmm what a person will pay for it
you're worth what someone will pay for
you now God gave his son to purchase you
and to redeem you that tells you what
your worth is you're worth the life of
the Son of God that you might be saved
that it will Auto increase your value
and your self perception of what you're
worth to God so yeah it doesn't need to
be the outward adorning and but if you
haven't read those books you know we'll
be happy to send them to you you can
actually read them online but the real
value comes from what God sees on the
inside and I'll appreciate your call
well thank you and we're gonna talk next
with Dawn
who is calling from Stephenville Texas
dawn you're on the air with Bible
answers live yes I get some mixed up
when I'm reading the Bible but when
Christ comes back and raised the people
from the grave uh-huh week down with him
right then back thirds for the thousand
years no it says in a revelation 20 we
live in reign with him for a thousand
years we know if you read in John
chapter 14 and the first few verses
Christ says I go to prepare a place for
you and if I go and prepare
place for you I will come again and
receive you unto myself that's when were
caught up to meet him in the air that
where I am with the father in the
father's house we may be also so he
comes down we're caught up we go to
heaven we live and reign with him in
glory for a thousand years and then it
says after the thousand years are
finished that's when the New Jerusalem
comes down from heaven out of God and
Christ creates a new heaven and new
earth after the great white throne
judgment and the wicked are destroyed
now I know I said that all very quickly
but it covers a number of things that
happen and we have a study guide that
talks in great detail about the
Millennium would you like to have a free
copy event yeah it's called a thousand
years of peace it's the main scriptures
you'll have everything you need there in
that one lesson to understand the
millennium it's very clear and it just
all the scripture starts to come
together and make sense if you take a
look at that it's called a thousand
years of peace just call 808 three five
six seven four seven we'll be happy to
send that to you Don and thank you I
appreciate your call hey where whereas
Stephenville Texas what part o seventy
miles be Northwest fourth oh okay well I
used to live in the dallas-fort Worth
area but I've heard of it but I couldn't
place it in my mind it thanks for
calling all right hey you go ahead and
give us a call another time we
appreciate your call friends that opens
up a phone line if you've got a question
then give us a call the phone number 800
god says with your Bible questions eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven and we're gonna be talking with
Edie
who's calling from Carr Blake Michigan
Michigan
Edie you're on the air with Bible
answers live yeah I thought I had just
got four thousand volts and something's
a big tongue came through the phone well
I wasn't my voice no it was like a big
surge or whatever but anyways pastor
I've been I was doing this amazing fact
study the this morning and about about
on the state of the Dead you know are
the dead really dead right and after I
get it all done in the back there in
bold numbers and then it says in numbers
seven those first Peter chapter four
verse six say that say the the gospel is
preached to the dead people right now I
know the answer because got the answer
there but yet still hold I don't know
how to say it it's still like a tongue
twister or whatever I can call it could
you explain that a little bit well let
me yeah let's let's read it to everybody
so that we you and I and everyone else
can listen in yeah first Peter chapter
four verse 6 it says for this is why the
gospel was preached to those who are
dead
that though though dead in the flesh of
the way they are they might live in the
spirit the way God does Paul talks about
people who are dead in trespasses and
sins and Christ came to us why we were
lost and he preaches to us in our dead
condition so that we might be revived it
doesn't mean that God preaches the
gospel to dead bodies first of all the
dead don't know anything and they can't
hear and so it's the living it says the
Bible tells us that the living will
praise the Lord once a man dies it says
appointed unto man wants to die and then
the judgment so God is not preaching to
the dead and you can also read about
that in Isaiah chapter 8 it says why
should the living consult the dead that
peep and mutter talking about evil
spirits he said you know we have a
Living God anyway I hope that helps a
little bit yet if you've done the study
are the dead really dead you might want
to ask for the free book that we've got
called spirits of the Dead
and if you call the resource number 883
five six seven four seven
well happy - we'll be happy to send you
a copy of that book Edie called seducing
spirits of the Dead and yeah people have
been deceived by King Saul was by a
spirit and it wasn't the Spirit of God
or the spirit of the Dead it was a
deceptive spirit revelation talks about
they are the spirits of Devil's working
miracles so we've got to know the dead
are sleeping they're not haunting people
hey thank you very much appreciate your
call in and with that we're gonna go and
talk to Reid who's calling from Peoria
Illinois Reid you're on the air with
Bible answers live hey good evening
pastor Doug how are you doing sir much
better than I deserve
how are you and what's up tonight okay
so I just get into the book of Acts
again I haven't read it for a while and
I was going through and I met the part
of you know in chapter 21 when Paul
saying his farewell to those those
apostles and where you get to the point
in chapter 21 verse 4 it says through
the spirit they urge Paul not to go on
to Jerusalem okay and then a little bit
after that in Chapter 11 they're talking
about this a prophet named Hagin the
campus yeah Agathis okay hey give us
thank you
and he says the Holy Spirit says in the
way the Jews of Jerusalem will bind the
owner of the belt of this bill and will
hand him over to the Gentiles so like so
my my question is is that maybe like a
warning for Paul not to go towards to do
that or is it more of like this is what
your fate is you know which is kind of
what Paul says after that so what was
your perspective on that when you read
that well yeah you know it does sound it
does sound confusing at first your
thinking is the Holy Spirit telling Paul
don't go or is the whole Holy Spirit
simply telling Paul this is what's gonna
happen to you you remember Jesus told
the Apostle Peter when you were young
and this is in John chapter 21 I think
it says when you're young you girded
yourself you went where you wanted but
when you're old
another will gird you and you'll stretch
forth your hands signifying how he would
die Peter
died of crucifixion Jesus told him in
advance this is how you're gonna die and
that doesn't mean that Peter you know
was now disobeying the Lord by going to
Rome in the same way Paul said look I I
feel compelled by the Lord to go to
Jerusalem God is just telling me that
imprisonment in Chains await me there
and he didn't remain in prison the rest
of his life he was in prison several
times but he was also released later
once he got to Rome but yeah he I think
God was just warning him of what to
expect
okay assume but just just wanted to see
what your what your respective earn
thank you for taking the time to answer
that question yeah absolutely now you
and I wonder if we were Paul would we
have gone yeah exactly it just be a
great a great test of our faith right
yeah so but you know I think we all get
to go through those kind of challenges
if we were called you know read there's
one more thing that just came to me when
Paul was being tried rah Ananias who
ended up baptizing Paul and I think
that's Acts chapter 9 God said Ananias
cuz in and I said Lord this is one
persecuting you and he said you know go
he's a chosen vessel of mine and I will
show him how much he must suffer for my
sake and so Paul was told in advance
that he would be suffering for Christ
because he had been a real pickle
persecuting the church so I think this
is was a continuation of that prophecy
that warning that God gave Paul thank
you and you know sometimes when God
tells us that we're going through hard
times he lets us know in advance that
we're gonna struggle just so that we'll
know he has not left us when we are
going through those trials it reminds us
he is with us because he saw it coming
all right guy appreciate that and we're
gonna see if we get another calling
before our break and talk to Jenna
who's calling from Crawford Texas Jenna
you're on the air listening on K SWF
your Bible question hard question okay
okay
when is it that God will wipe away all
tears you know because I've read it in
the Bible there's a library all tears
and I've heard it's been sort of a
controversy so I'm a bit confused
will he do this after the millennium
before the millennium and the second
part if he does it after the millennium
I mean will be sad The Fader will be sad
in heaven and even if he does it after
the destruction of the wicked will the
say to see their loved ones burning and
will they hear their you know their
screeches and swings that'll all be I'd
be pretty difficult with it well let me
give you something to think about when
Jesus was on the cross was there sadness
in heaven yeah so I think sometimes
we've got the idea that once Jesus comes
that all emotion is somehow erased and
we're just you know we're kind of
grinning robots when we get to heaven
we're gonna learn a lot and have a lot
of questions we're gonna see people that
are not there that we thought would be
there we're gonna see maybe some loved
ones or friends that are not there we're
gonna see people there and we're
wondering how the world they got in and
we're gonna have a probably a spectrum
of emotions God says in Revelation 21
after the New Jerusalem comes down he'll
wipe away all tears from their eyes and
so during the millennium and during this
great 1000 year judgment when we're
asking questions and there may be some
sorrow you know I think we're gonna get
to heaven some of us when we see the
incredible glory that God's prepared for
us we'll be thinking wow I wasted so
much time even though I'm saved
and I thank the Lord I there's so much
more I could have done a lot of people
will probably even have some regrets
that we had not done more to warn people
and share and so the idea that we have
no emotion in heaven and there's no
feeling that there's only happiness in
heaven
we will have pleasure at his right hand
forevermore once we enter eternity but
before the wicked are destroyed there's
gonna be some sorrow I think doesn't
mean we're gonna be crying for a
thousand years I think they'll be joy
unspeakable but we'll probably have
twinges of grief when we think about
people that could have been
I mean you know how can we be totally
void of any emotion not feeling the
vacuum of some loved ones that we could
have you know that could have warned or
that are not there so yeah and there'll
be varying degrees of even joy Jesus
said there's varying degrees of reward
and so that's the varying degrees of
punishment varying degrees of good
reward as well anyway I hope that helps
did that answer your your question but I
always thought that wouldn't there would
be no there there will be no tears in
heaven when when God ultimately wipes
away all tears and but I believe that
and don't misunderstand when we're first
caught up to meet the Lord and we get
our glorified bodies we're gonna be so
joyful but when we're up there and still
using our heads I think we're gonna
think and I think we're gonna notice
some people are not they're just like
we're gonna notice some people are there
and rejoice so yeah I think the Angels
are sad angels rejoice when someone's
saved but I think angels grieve when
someone's lost so like the Angels will
have emotions and while we're in heaven
but once we entered the thousand years
and we see that God did everything he
could to save as many as he could then
all of those sad memories will be
forever washed away and you know if you
have not seen it yet Jenna you would
also appreciate that free study guide we
offered a little earlier and it's
talking about the 1,000 years of peace
dealing with the millennium and if you
call the resource number that's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven we will send you a free copy of
that one more time 800 eight three five
six seven four seven we do have a couple
of lines open if you want to call in
with a Bible question that's a different
number that's 800 God says 800 for six
three seven two nine seven you're
listening the Bible answers live
we've got more Bible questions coming
give us a call we'll be back in just a
couple of minutes
Bible answers live return in just a
moment if you're looking for Bible based
materials for further study sign up for
amazing faxes free correspondence Bible
study course or check out our sale
catalogue featuring hundreds of
inspiring books and tapes to order call
our resource line at 800 eight three
five six seven four seven that's 800
eight three five six seven four seven
amazing facts is a faith-based
listener-supported ministry operating
exclusively through the generosity of
your prayers and financial gifts we
would love to hear from you write to us
at peel box 909 Roseville California
nine five six seven eight or online at
amazing facts org you're listening to
Bible answers live with Pastor Doug
Batchelor if you have a Bible related
question call us now to receive clear
honest answers directly from scripture
we have a few lines open so please give
us a call the phone number to the studio
is 800 God says that's eight hundred
four sixty three seven two nine seven if
you've enjoyed Bible answers life you'll
love Pastor Doug's book of Bible answers
straight from the broadcast the very
best questions and answers have been
compiled as an awesome resource for
Bible study and personal evangelism each
answer has been expanded with more Bible
verses and insightful commentary the
book of Bible answers can be yours today
for just $12 call now 1-888-665-4483
back again and be live with you and
we're gonna go back to the phones now
by the way people in New Zealand and
Fiji hear the program too many of them
listen on the internet talking next with
let's see Rick is calling Rick calling
from lumber to New Jersey listening on
Sirius XM and your question Rick the
recent attack on Paris how would that
fit in with prophecy you know it's
interesting today the Pope in his you
know at the time of this recording were
live and Sunday morning in Vatican City
the Pope gave a message where he talked
about signs of the second coming and he
specifically mentioned the the Paris
terrorism attack and I thought that was
interesting and then the radio interview
he was asked by the bishops if he
thought that this was so the Pope has
said in the past he thinks that World
War three is going to be happening in
piecemeal that's I guess the English
translation of a world war three that
will happen in little pieces all over
the place and he said he thinks this is
part of World War three in piecemeal
where it's like they'll be tax you know
everywhere that are hard to pin down so
that's interesting you would ask that
and I wondered before the program since
it's been just filling the news
certainly you can't miss the very
important truth the two largest
religions in the world numerically
Christianity number one by numbers and
of course not everyone on the books as a
Christian is a practicing credit
Christian it's just the Christians
number more than Muslims which are
number two Hinduism and Buddhism fall
you know far third and fourth you could
see we're in the final events there
would be some kind of a showdown it
seems like the hostilities between
radical Islam and Christianity are
intensifying and so it is also
interesting and I want to be careful not
to go out on a limb but when you look at
Daniel chapter 12
just before Michael stands
and there's a great time of trouble it
mentions in chapter 11 you'll find I
think six different countries are
mentioned that are surrounded Israel
which Israel being the seventh
it's got Edom Moab Ammon and then it
talks about the Libyans Ethiopia and
Egypt and Libya and I think it's just
very interesting that it mentions six of
what are Islamic countries today so I do
think some of wondered if in Daniel
we're talks about the king of the north
and the King of the South is if this is
somehow also talking about a showdown
between these two great religions and I
want to be careful to say I don't have
all the answers on that but I definitely
believe that conflict between Islam and
Christianity is going to be a factor in
the final events and it has been in
Christian history and prophecy in the
past and I think it's going to play a
role in the future
so that's a long meandering answer Rick
I'm sorry yeah what we see in that
direction I don't see a political answer
to this because in a radical Islam if
they are just bent on the destruction of
Western society and it's a religious
problem it's not a political problem and
these you know you it's the only way to
combat these religious problems it takes
many years of education to change
people's thinking and there's a whole
generation of young radical Muslims
right now that just feel like the the
Western nations America and Europe are
the devil and they think they're doing a
good thing by attacking and you know
these attacks in France were celebrated
by these groups so there's some
deep-rooted problems there that I think
will play out in lasts a prophecy I
appreciate that question Rick it gave me
an opportunity to vent some of my
thoughts that I've been processing all
right with that though we need to move
on we're gonna talk with a Debra who is
calling from Brooklyn New York Debra
you're on the air with Bible answers
live
spool of John and Gospel chapter 12
verse 40 he has blinded their eyes and
hardened their hearts lest they should
be with their eyes lest they should
understand with their hearts and turn so
that I should heal them could you give
me an understanding to that please yeah
first of all Jesus is quoting Isaiah 6
and 9 Isaiah 6 9 says go and say to
these people keep on hearing but do not
understand keep on seen but do not
perceive and you know when Jesus said it
you're reading the Greek translation of
the Hebrew prophecy um
he's basically saying that because they
have hardened their hearts they may see
but they won't recognize or discern and
they may hear but they won't understand
because without the Holy Spirit you
can't see or blind are being led by the
blind and without the Holy Spirit we
cannot hear that's why in Revelation it
says he that has ears let him hear what
the Spirit says and Jesus tells us
spiritual things or Paul actually says
spiritual things are spiritually
discerned so that's why Christ even
spoke in parables that people that were
searching would find the answers but
those whose hearts were hard you know
they won't even be accountable because
they they just weren't open yeah anybody
and there's some claimed to be
Christians but they won't really hear
the truth they don't repent of their
sins because they've hardened their
hearts to the spirit and so you know
Jesus doesn't want anyone to be lost he
would have all men to be saved but some
people have eyes and don't see I mean
the best example of what Christ is
talking about is the religious leaders
they claim to be waiting for the Messiah
and here was the Messiah right in front
of them they didn't recognize him Bible
says he came unto his own and his own
knew it not they hear his words and they
didn't recognize it and they wanted to
kill him seeing they did not see hearing
they did not understand because their
hearts were hard but some of them like
Nicodemus and Joseph of Arimathea is
some of the Pharisees later Paul they
did soften
their hearts and they didn't see and
understand so it just it's a question of
a heart condition alright thanks for
your call Debra appreciate it and with
that we're going to talk within calling
from Detroit Michigan hi Ann you're on
the air with hi I was in Lansing
Michigan not too long ago so we're glad
you're calling you know there is a
passage in the book of Hebrews that it
says be careful to entertain strangers
because some have entertained angels
unaware and so the Bible is filled with
examples of angels appearing to humans
in human form you can think of when an
angel appeared to the wife of manoa
Samson's parents and when an angel
appeared to Gideon and angels appeared
to lot and many others in the Bible and
they entertained angels they brought him
into their home angels have guided the
disciples you know when they first
looked in the tomb Mary Magdalene and
the others they saw two angels but they
thought there were two men at first and
they said why are you seeking the living
among the dead so whether or not you or
somebody is seeing angels that are
calling them to do something or
impressing them that could be you know I
could speculate whether or not they are
I guess an eternity we'll know the
answer to that but sometimes the spirit
will bear witness and say you know these
are my messengers and and usually they
give a message they don't just look at
you but you know we have a lesson that
talks about angels we'll be happy to
send you a free copy in and it's called
angel messages from outer space angel
messages from space and it talks about
three angel messages in Revelation
chapter 14 that come to earth just
before Jesus returns you would want to
read that we'll send you that free
lesson here's the number if you call 808
three five six seven four seven ask for
our lesson on angel messages and we'll
send that to you 808 three five six
seven four seven thank you very much and
for your call with that we're gonna be
talking with Mickey
who's calling from Cedar Hill California
Mickey you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi pastor dad how are you
doing good how are you very good
my question for you tonight do we pray
to the Holy Spirit you I would say no I
wouldn't say a person's sinned if they
do but I just when you look at the Bible
I would ask where in the Bible do you
see a prayer addressed to the Holy
Spirit the Holy Spirit is the person of
the Godhead you know the function of God
the Father is different from God the Son
God the Father so loved the world he
sent God the Son Jesus is our example
he's our mediator and Jesus said I'm
going to the Father that I can send God
the Spirit and the purpose and the work
of the Spirit he describes as to bring
comfort and conviction and so and
guidance so the Holy Spirit's work is
very different from Jesus work but we're
principally in the Bible we pray to the
Father in the name of Jesus but we pray
in the spirit so that there's a
difference between praying in the spirit
as Paul says in first Corinthians 14 as
praying to the spirit so the spirit is
not the one we're appealing to we can
pray to God for the Holy Spirit
but you see what I'm saying so you know
I've you may hear people from time to
time pray to the spirit and you know I I
wanted to fault them for doing that but
if you go through the examples in the
Bible they're always calling out to the
Father in Jesus name there is one
example that I know of there may be
others but there's one example I know of
that in Acts chapter 7 when Stephen is
dying he prays to Jesus he says Lord
Jesus receive my spirit but all the
other prayers are addressed to the
Father in Christ's name so you know I
know we teach little children to pray
dear Jesus and and God understands that
I'm just being technical I hope it
doesn't sound unspiritual
no absolutely and we appreciate your
calling and we do have a lesson that
deals with the Father Son and Holy
Spirit it's actually a book I've written
on the Trinity and I'll send you a copy
that Mickey if you want a free copy it's
called the Trinity is it biblical and
just call 883 five six seven four seven
and we'll be happy to send that to you
appreciate your call
talking next with Steve from San Mateo
California listening on ke dia Steve
you're on the air with Bible answers
live are you doing better than I deserve
how are you doing why does God punish us
if we disobey Him so meaning if God
gives us rewards if we obey Him and he
punishes us if we disobey Him and that's
why a lot of people obey because they
don't want to get punished if they say
like there was no punishment for
disobeying God nobody well are you a
parent I am do you want your children to
obey you just because you're gonna
punish them if they don't or do you want
them to obey you because they trust you
love you and believe what you're asking
is in their best interest yeah that
makes it I want I want him I want him to
obey me because I advise that I give him
this or that their own good and that's
what God wants now it is true that God
will punish sin but he doesn't do it
just to destroy he does it to save a lot
of times we get
chastened by the Lord and it says in
Hebrews don't despise the chastening or
the discipline of God because whom the
Lord loves he chastens now when my kids
were little it's easier to understand
this when they're they're younger if I
saw them sticking a paperclip or a
screwdriver in an outlet I would tell
them no if no didn't work I'd swap their
hand and it wasn't because I didn't love
them but I'd much rather them feel the
little stinging pain of my swatting
their hand and feel it can't be killed
by electricity it's cuz I do love them
that I would chase in them you know what
I mean and every parent at some point
has to teach their children obey me when
I say get out of the street get out of
the street they don't listen you've got
to teach them to listen or because it
means their life and so God sometimes
disciplines his children because he
wants to save us because He loves us and
so he wants us to trust him that
everything God asks us to do is good God
will withhold no good thing and this is
a scripture God will withhold no good
thing from those that walk uprightly and
because He loves us and that's in Psalms
I can't remember the verse so because He
loves us he wants to give us every good
and perfect gift and we need to trust
him there are things that he says we
shouldn't do because they bring pain and
misery and you know any sin that you
could think of when you play it out it
ends up bringing death it ends up
causing problems obedience brings life
and goodness and joy it's true it's very
true I agree with you hundred percent
but we could not be neither fat lot of
people obey God because they want to get
destroyed you're right there's some
people that obey because of a desire for
heaven and they want to avoid hell and
you know that's a starting point but he
doesn't you know if we if God saves us
and the only thing we're doing is
obeying him because we are afraid of him
that's the wrong reason he will and if
you get to heaven you won't want to obey
Him anymore so we need to learn to obey
Him because we love Him because God is
love and he that what's the great
command if we're gonna obey Him he says
the great command is love him with all
of our heart mind soul and strength hey
thank you very much Steve appreciate
your call
with that we're gonna be talking we're
the Nick who is calling from well where
are you calling from Minnesota
okay hi Nick I couldn't say the name of
the town Malacca Malacca Malak alright
yeah and your question tonight my
question is what is your view on grace
versus law while we deliver lives on a
gray faces after death or according to
the law of Scripture
well Bible's pretty clear that we are
saved by grace through faith
but he goes on to say we are saved to
obey in other words God doesn't save us
by grace to license us for disobedience
because we we don't obey God to be saved
we obey God or at least should because
we are saved and one of the reasons yeah
I believe that is if you look in Exodus
when God saved the children of Israel
Paul says in 1st Corinthians 10 this is
an example analogy an allegory of
salvation when he saved them he didn't
come to the Israelites and say here's my
law keep the Ten Commandments and I'll
get you out of here he came to them
instead sacrifice this Ram and after
they sacrificed the lamb they began a
journey to the promised land it's
through the lamb that they were saved
then after they were saved he gave them
the law so you see what I'm saying so I
yeah we obey because we are saved
because we love Him
jesus said if you love me john 14 if you
love me keep my Commandments that's the
reason to obey but we're saved by grace
so like you know the thief that died on
the cross next to Jesus and he's jesus
said to him you'll be with me in
paradise just suppose that man was saved
he didn't do any good works he was saved
by faith you look to Jesus said Lord
remember me he isn't saved entirely by
faith but just suppose for whatever
reason that man was taken off the cross
and given a chance to live would he live
differently because of God's grace well
I think so and one of the important
things about God's grace he gives us
grace to obey His grace is not to
empower us to disobey
he gives us power to obey so that's kind
of a quick hey you know what I'd like to
do Nick if you let me I'll send you I've
got a book on a great
and it's called does God's grace blot
out the law it's a great book does God's
grace blot out the law and it explains a
beautiful relationship between grace and
the law and those covenants in the Bible
in the New Testament thank you for your
call Nick oh by the way the number is
883 five six seven four seven does God's
grace blot out the law we'll send that
to you or anybody if you're interested
in that question you call that number
we'll send you the book you can even
read the book for free by going to the
amazing facts dot o-r-g website and
gonna talk next with Kevin from Edmonton
Canada you're on the air doing well how
are you pretty good pretty good just
question regarding witnessing for jeans
I'm wondering you know if we fail to
witness for Jesus is it a fun date is
there a penalty because I've read you
know verses what if you hide your light
or yeah double up in you know I mean
like it can you help me well you know
the Bible tells us if we confess with
our mouth and leave with our heart the
Lord Jesus will be saved confess with
our mouth means you know let your light
shine it says in revelation they
overcome by the blood of the Lamb and
the word of their testimony so you know
I think that part of the Christian life
is you know we read our Bibles we pray
and then we share our faith you've got
three articles of furniture in the holy
place of the temple you've got a
candlestick which is letting your light
shine you've got the bread which is the
Bible and you've got an altar of incense
Revelation tells us that's prayer those
are the three disciplines of the
Christian life feed your soul with the
word of God pray communicate with God
and tell others so the great command is
love the Lord and then love your
neighbor and the way you love your
neighbor is by letting your light shine
now that doesn't mean Kevin not
everybody's a teacher and a preacher but
there are different ways that God gives
us gifts to use our light and hopefully
he's he's gonna let you I have one of
those gifts as well
now Kevin I don't know it seems like we
may have lost you I apologize if we did
but um so yes I'd say if I are you back
on oh yeah yeah so does that make sense
yeah yeah all right hey thank you very
much appreciate your your question and
trying to think if we've got a study
guide that might yeah we've got a Bible
study guide to call teach us to pray
talks about the Christian life and we'll
send you a free copy that 808 three five
six seven four seven and we'll send you
the book teach us to pray going next to
talk with Gary listening on satellite
radio Gary you're on the air yeah I kind
of like a time to want to piggyback off
of what you just said in terms of loving
your neighbor and my and my
understanding but best understanding it
would that's probably or I'm guessing
that's one of the requirements in terms
of being saved but also based on what
I've read through Scripture and by what
I've been listening hearing in terms of
what other pastors have been saying I've
written it a checklist of five things
that would be requirements in terms of
being saved and I'm gonna I'll just
rattle them off to you real quickly and
I wanted to get your feedback and number
one is confess with your tongue number
two believe in your heart
number three being baptized number four
repentance of sins and number five
having the love of God which would be
agape and I wanted to get your feedback
and whether you'd like to add to that
well I put I think you've got a great
list I think I put confession repentance
kind of together because a part of
repentance is confessing your sin your
sorrow Fersen whoever repents and
confesses will have mercy and whoever
forsakes their sin will have mercy as
well it says and then believing and I
don't know if you specifically said that
but you know we are saved by faith and
so it's so important to believe if we
confess our sins he is faithful and just
to forgive us our sins and
cleanse us from all unrighteousness we
need to believe that and so it's a life
of faith of believing that God walks
with us
sharing your faith and then it says if
you believe baptism is certainly part of
that now there'll be some people in
heaven obviously who were not baptized
because you've got you know all these
Old Testament heroes that maybe didn't
know about baptism and like the thief on
the cross but every believer who can be
baptized should be baptized that's why
Jesus said go teach baptize teaching
them to observe all things that I've
commanded you and so it's interesting
Gary this week amazing facts is gonna be
recording five steps to salvation that's
and it's I think nothing's a coincidence
with God but it's funny that you would
call and mention that because I was just
going through the five steps of
salvation today in our script we're
gonna do a YouTube that people can then
send to their friends and say what do I
need to do to be saved here are the five
steps biblically how you can you know go
through the process of salvation we
cover it in just two and a half or three
minutes and we lead a person in a prayer
where they can receive Christ and we
would just like to see this salvation
invitation go viral thank you for your
call Gary by the way we do have a book
we'll send you that covers the steps of
salvation for free it's called three
steps to heaven three steps to heaven
and just call and ask for that eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven I apologize friends if you call
you did not get on the air tonight God
willing we'll be back next week give us
a chance then and remember there is so
much more of amazing facts on the
website you'll find out about our weekly
television programs we're on the
Discovery Channel we're on lifetime
network and many others just go to
amazing facts dot o-r-g find out not
only about the radio programs and
stations in your area but the TV
programs and the incredible publishing
ministry amazing facts dot our gfriend's
also we are listener based if you've
been blessed keep us on the air you can
click and donate online and share the
good news with others
god bless well study his word together
again next week
[Music]
this has been a pre-recorded broadcast
of Bible answers live a production of
amazing facts ministries if you would
like to order the materials mention on
this broadcast call 808 three five six
seven four seven from 8:00 a.m. to
midnight Eastern Standard Time
that's 808 three five six seven four
seven if you've missed an episode of
Bible answers live you can find it on
our website amazing facts dot o-r-g
you'll also find our online sale catalog
of books tapes and other materials as
well as numerous free resources on
nearly every Bible topic putting the
answers to your Bible questions right at
your fingertips if you've been blessed
by this program let us know write to us
at p o-- box nano nine Roseville
California nine five six seven eight be
sure to tell others about the program
and join us again next time for more
viable answers live with pastor Doug
Batchelor they grew up in a church-going
family I mean we were at every meeting I
sang in four of the choirs there I
directed three very involved very active
it almost seemed like busywork sometimes
you know I went to Sunday school I knew
about God I knew about Jesus but I
didn't have a personal relationship with
Jesus Christ my senior year in high
school I got the news that my father had
been murdered
I played it off well no one really saw
that I was struggling with it it just
really felt like there was a hole that
needed to be filled and I tried to fill
it with drugs alcohol was partying after
college I just stopped going to church
all together one day on the Sunday cuz I
didn't feel like going to church with my
mom I thought you know I should get a
little bit of work
she had the satellite system hooked up
and I'm flipping through channels and
then the logo pops across amazing facts
presents I've listened to a lot of
different ministers but here this was
the first time and he's actually saying
something where I had to grab my Bible
actually pick it up and I've never heard
this before let me let me look through
and find this I went through all the
store rules I went through all the study
guides and I just couldn't get enough
and then the Sabbath came on and he's
going through the appeal and I'm just
going Lord I hear you I have to go to
the church so I show up it was funny I
didn't feel like I was gonna be judged
anything judgmental anything I walked in
the door and I just felt at home but
there's still a problem
I'm still partying I was still going out
to the bars at this time I was selling
cocaine to pay my rent 16 days later I
find myself in a life-or-death situation
I just came back from the liquor store
and grabbed a bottle of vodka and there
I am high off cocaine with my Bible in
hand trying to do a Bible study and I
heard an audible voice just look at
yourself
and I did and I was like what am i doing
and I got all my knees I said Lord if
you do not take this away from me now
I'm going to kill myself I was going to
continue this lifestyle and I was gonna
end up overdosing having a heart attack
whatever it was you have to take this
away all of it and that day he lifted
all of it away it was all God when God
does something in your life he does it
complete
[Music]
for more than 45 years the Ministry of
amazing facts has been helping people
from all walks of life understand their
Bibles better than ever before through
television radio and the Internet we
impact countless lives each day around
the world by sharing Bible truth that
transforms lives forever if you've been
blessed by our programs will you help
share in this work with a tax-deductible
gift today when you support amazing
facts you give lasting hope and make it
possible for others to hear the good
news of Jesus Christ and experience his
eternal love to give a gift call
[Music]
you